18 Mio hier liege General das letztmals
das gesehen habe war der zehnte April
der was noch vor dem Abitur und Arbeit
verstehen sie Spaß
um
ich wollte aber Frank ist der geht
und Prozent
die ersten Bahnen sind wegsteckt und
das Duo auf Tour aufbricht sich mit der
Zeit das mit ganz normalen Leuten sein
Freunde und Kumpels
um am 2 in Hannover Essen zu gehen
wenn ich hier es geben
ich danke dir ich hoffe die geht auch
gut
macht doch nichts oder mach das was mit
dem Ton
wenn ich jetzt keinen Abbruch tun wobei
der Heimat
man kann nicht immer alles haben wir
einen jungen ich habe deshalb weil für
diesen kurzen Exkurs
einige Klubs ich habe mein Abitur
bestanden ich habe abgeben hier müssen
vom Konzept geworden und 2 falls das
noch nicht reicht
eine Katze ich bin wie eine jetzt muss
ich denen wir auf und ich arbeite sehr
viele und Prozent
um nicht
ich fühle mich gut und vielleicht sieht
man sich ja mal wieder
auf der einen oder anderen vorstellen
könnte